hi there
steve here um i'm having trouble with my
uh whole
video production system here uh for some
reason uh youtube is rejecting my
imovie movies so i'm gonna do a short
one here and just see if it works i've
made a few changes
i'm going to talk about philosophy for
children i was listening to a
a podcast on tsf podcast out of portugal
i'm going to put the link and notes to
this video and there was an interview
with a gentleman who was proposing
you know uh to uh have more philosophy
for kids
from the ages of i guess six seven or so
up to nine 10 11 in schools
and i thought was very interesting
because he said that number one
that the first thing is to teach kids to
listen
and i think it's very important for
people to learn to listen
just as well as it is to learn to read
and we know that a lot of people who
have trouble
reading they have trouble because they
haven't heard very much they haven't
listened to
a lot of stuff at home maybe their
parents didn't talk about
things in whatever language the native
language
um so the more people listen the more
kids listen the more they're aware of
different things
uh have general knowledge the easier it
is for them to read the
easier it is for them to to infer and
understand things they don't need
teachers to teach them critical thinking
they need to have heard a lot so
listening number one
yes philosophy for children teach kids
to listen
number two is that the group the class
20 people or so becomes a kind of a
community of
inquiry of investigation they are going
to collectively
study a subject debated discuss it
whatever but it's a community
that is discussing things excellent
third point is that they're going to
debate
but they're not going to arrive at a
consensus this is not about
a consensus and this is very much in
contrast to the prevailing
ideology in north american academia
where
you have to kind of dialogue and see if
we can't find
common ground and we have to agree no
no disagree learn to disagree
learn to debate learn to defend your
ideas and learn to accept
that other people have different ideas
and that's perfectly
acceptable everyone doesn't have to
agree because what happens is
when you have this this ideology of
everyone agreeing
it means that there is a a basically a
program
pre-established we all agree that this
is good and this is bad
and so that the dialogue so-called is
all about how do we get everyone to
agree upon
something which is the predetermined
agenda
no freedom let kids express themselves
let them disagree let them challenge so
the idea that kids would do this in the
classroom and that the teachers would
not try to impose
a set of values that they all have to
agree to
is a great idea so a great podcast
i if you understand portuguese i suggest
you listen to it
thank you for listening